- Hey, guys, welcome everybody.
I'm Heinrich from Firm
Learning from this channel.
Thank you for watching.
Today is going to cover another topic
around the blockchain technology.
You maybe have already
seen the introductory video
that I posted a couple of days ago.
If you haven't, I posted
a link here on top,
please click on it and you
will be directed to it.
This section is again
an excerpt of my course
on blockchain technology
that are linked down below
into the description.
If you would like to learn more about it
and get a more holistic
view, check out the link.
We have roughly 10,000 students
signed up in the course.
You can read some reviews if
you would like to learn more.
But anyhow, in the next minutes,
you will get just a section
of that for you for free.
And this section will cover something
that is called consensus
mechanism, the consensus mechanism.
And that is a fundamental
piece to understand
if you would like to learn
more on a more technical level,
how blockchains work.
It's really at the core,
it's fundamental building of
every blockchain out there.
So if you're interested, hang on.
I trust you will learn a lot about that.
And let me know in the comments
if you have any questions
or feedback, I'm very happy to answer it.
This lecture is all about
distributed consensus.
Distributed consensus is
a really important topic
to learn about, if you want to understand
the ins and outs of blockchain.
So let's directly jump into it.
And what I would like to start with
is to contrast once
more centralized systems
with decentralized
systems like blockchains.
A centralized system is a
system where every participant
in the system is linked with each other
by some kind of central instance.
An example would be a bank.
So think about how you
interact with a bank.
You can go to a bank as a simple person
and open a bank account.
You can facilitate transactions
through the bank by going
to the bank and submitting
a transaction and so on.
And what's your characteristic
is that the bank
is in the middle of
everything that happens
and can decide whether a
transaction is valid or not.
If there's some kind of dispute
that one participant says
or claims that the transaction
that he got was not valid,
then the bank steps into it,
investigates it and make
some kind of resolution
to the dispute that was filed.
A decentralized system, like bitcoin
or any kind of blockchain
works differently.
There is no such thing as
a centralized institution
that decides which
transactions are valid or not,
who is right, how the system
is operated, and so on.
And this begs a significant number
of very important questions
that need to be answered
when designing a distributed
system like a blockchain.
One of these questions is who
runs the distributed ledger?
We already learned that
a blockchain is one way
of distributing a ledger
through large number
of individual nodes.
But who's responsible for making sure
that the ledger is up to date
with all the different nodes out there?
The second question would be,
who decides which transactions are valid?
So now imagine the case
of a cryptocurrency.
And you submit a
transaction to the network
in which you claim that
somebody else transferred you
a significant amount of coins.
And especially, if this
claim is fraudulent,
how does the network make
sure that you are caught
and that your transaction
that you filed gets rejected
as invalid?
And in the case of crypto
currencies, of course,
the question that is up in the air is,
who can create new coins?
And then the last question,
how are all these kind of
meter level rules decided?
Who decides and who can change
these rules of the system
that determine the
answers to these questions
that we just formulated.
And the answer is consensus.
There needs to be
something in place called
a consensus mechanism
that facilitates consensus
between the individual nodes
and kind of it's a system
of rules that decides
who is right and what happens
if somebody wants to do
something in the network.
And something like that is just required
to get productive distributed system.
Because of course, it
will rarely be the case
in a very large distributed system,
that every single one
agrees with something.
There will be a dispute
and a consensus mechanism
is the way to resolve this dispute.
There are certain number of
different consensus mechanisms
out there in the world of blockchain
that are used by different
types of blockchains.
And what I want to do now
is I want to kind of give
you a glimpse overview,
a quick overview or
the most important ones
and then go into detail
in the next lectures.
First, on proof of work.
And second, of proof of stake,
because these two mechanisms
are probably the most important
and the most relevant ones up to date.
But in this overview, now
let's start with proof of work.
Proof of work is probably
the most widely known consensus mechanism,
because it was introduced by bitcoin.
And of course, bitcoin is
something like the godfather
of all block chains and
of all cryptocurrencies.
And just kind of a
disclaimer at the beginning,
before we go into these next sections,
to really understand these things,
you need to get very, very technical,
and I will not go into that
level of technicality with you.
What I want to do with you
is give you the intuition
that helps you understand
how these things work
on a more qualitative level,
which means that I will need
to simplify a number of things,
so please forgive me if you
already have more knowledge
about that, that the things
that I'm teaching you now
are to a certain degree simplified.
So back to proof of
work, how does it work?
But the basic intuition is
that you as a node can opt in
to contribute computing
power to the network.
And by doing that, you
have the network to run.
And then proof of work
means that those nodes
that contribute more computing
power to the network,
have more say in the network.
And for instance, in the case of bitcoin,
it works the way that if you
contribute computing power,
then you participate
in some kind of puzzle
and some kind of cryptographic puzzle
that you want to solve.
And if you are the one
that solves this puzzle,
and the more computing
power you contribute,
the higher your chances
are of winning the puzzle.
And if you are the one
who wins the puzzle,
you have the right to propose
the next block of transactions
to the network.
And then the other nodes can verify that
and if they believe that
your transactions are valid,
then the block gets
added to the blockchain.
And then at some point in the future,
the next block gets proposed.
So the more computing power you provide,
the more say you have in the network.
And bitcoin is one popular
example using that.
Another one would be Litecoin.
And there are large number
of other coins doing that
as well.
A bit more modern alternative
to that is proof of stake.
Instead of using kind of computing power
as the decisive factor,
the coin holding of the
individual nodes are used.
So the more coins you hold,
kind of the more of a way,
the more of a very rich
person you are in the network,
the more say you have in the network,
and the larger your chances
of you being the one
who can propose the next
transactions to the network.
And you can imagine this as
some kind of lottery system,
where you get more tickets,
the more coins you have.
And the more tickets you have, of course,
the higher your chances of winning are
and winning means kind of
making decisions in the network.
And two popular examples are Lisk or Neo,
even though I'm aware that
for Neo it can be debated
whether this is actually
an arch type proof of stake
or maybe also different,
but probably that could
go too far if we dive
into that right now.
A third consensus mechanism introduced
by new economic movement,
NEM, is proof of information,
sorry, proof of importance.
And here, the decision
to be made, who decides,
who makes the decisions in the network
are based on the network activity
and the reputation within the network.
So simply put, the more
useful you are to the network,
the more say you have,
and your level of usefulness is determined
by a certain number of factors
that then also every blockchain
can set for themselves.
NEM is the coin that
popularized or introduced
this proof of work mechanism.
And then there are a couple
of others like proof of burn,
proof of capacity, proof
of activity and so on.
In each one of them, every one of them
has distinctive advantages
and disadvantages.
And this is also the
point that I would like
to close this lecture with.
To date, there's no one
single consensus mechanism
that is generally believed
to be the very best one.
Every single one has
advantages and disadvantages.
So coins make different choices.
Blockchains can make
different choices depending
on what is important to them.
And probably one step further,
probably in the future,
new consensus mechanisms
will arise which we haven't
been thinking about so far.
And then these new consensus
mechanisms might be then
the gold standard in the future.
So the field of consensus
mechanisms is a quickly
and steadily evolving
one kind of fighting for
or searching for the very
best mechanism that fulfills
the need of the individual
blockchain applications
that you want to build.
This lecture focuses
on the proof of work consensus mechanism.
And before we go into more detail
about how proof of work works,
let's first recap why there is a need
for something like consensus mechanism.
The consensus mechanism
fundamentally wants to answer
the question, what will
be the next valid block
of the blockchain?
And if you think about it,
you have the blockchain.
And now there are all kinds of miners
and all kinds of open
transactions out there,
but who decides what the
next block is going to be?
And of course, there needs to be consensus
around this question.
Everybody in the network
needs to understand and agree
on what the next block needs to be.
So let's go into this
one level more detail
and just understand this issue
on a bit more systematic level.
So this is a stylized
version of the blockchain.
So just imagine already some blocks filled
with transaction data that
has occurred in the past.
And now the next level
block needs to be selected.
And the block is
fundamentally nothing else
than a collection of
transactions that have occurred.
So what exactly this
means is that if you want
to post the transaction to the network,
so let's think about the bitcoin network,
you want to send somebody money,
you post the transaction
to the bitcoin blockchain.
And this transaction lands
in something that is called,
especially in the bitcoin community,
a memory pool or short, mempool.
So the mempool consists of all the open,
unconfirmed transactions posted
to the blockchain network.
But in order for them now to be validated,
they need to be included
in the official blockchain
and one of the blocks.
So now a miner comes, he
picks up some transactions
which are currently floating
around in the mempool
and aggregates them into the next block
and he now tries to post this
next block to the blockchain.
So many miners are
competing against each other
in order to post one
block to the blockchain.
But of course, only one
block can be the next block
that actually gets added to it.
So how do you decide which miner
is the one that gets chosen
to publish the next block.
And in order for this proof
of work comes into play,
and kind of to put it shortly,
to propose a new block,
a miner need to show something
that is called Nonce.
A Nonce value that together
with all other block inputs
produces a hash value within
a certain valid range.
So this is something that is
also called a hash puzzle.
Different miners compete with each other
in order to solve the hash puzzle.
And the miner that first
solves this hash puzzle
is the one that can post
the block to the blockchain.
To understand this a bit further,
so what is the hash puzzle?
So just the visualization here,
imagine this is the
complete range of values
that a hash function can take.
So remember back at the
introductory section
where we introduced
what hash functions are,
hash functions are functions that take
whatever input you have, you
can put any input into it,
and then they give you a certain output
for the input value that you inserted.
So measuring this range of
values to be the complete range
of values that the hash function
can give you as an output.
Then the algorithm defines
that only a certain part
of that hash function
would be considered valid.
So this means that often it's done the way
that there's a threshold,
a value threshold,
so you need to come up with a hash output
that has kind of a number or certain value
below a certain threshold
that is being defined.
Now also, again, think back
at the stylized blockchain
that we talked about earlier
where we saw the different blocks.
And we changed the values
and saw how the different
hash functions concatenated
the individual blocks to one blockchain.
We saw that there was one
value that was called Nonce.
And it's called Nonce,
it stands for nonsense,
this is barely what it means.
So this has no intrinsic value,
except for the miners
needing to find the Nonce,
that together with all the
other content of a block
that they want to propose,
if all this content,
including the Nonce is put
into a hash function,
the output of this hash
function fulfills the criterion
of validity that is given here,
or kind of has a value
that is considered valid
by the network.
And this is basically done by
nothing else, the brute force.
The miner needs to try
lots and lots and lots
of different Nonce values
in order to come up with
the kind of total hash
output that is valid.
And the smaller the range
of valid hash outcomes is,
of course, the more difficult
it is for the miner to come up
or to find the Nonce value
that makes the equation valid.
So, kind of in a bit more
systematic way or technical way,
what is the proof of work?
Proof of work is a piece of data.
So, something like the Nonce
or maybe the Nonce combined
with the other inputs
that then give a hash function output
that is costly and time
consuming to produce.
In order to find that,
you will need to brute force
try lots and lots and lots
of different Nonce values
in order to come up
with the value that is valid.
And it needs to be easy
to verify the validity
of the value by others.
So if a miner now believes
that he has found the solution
and posts this block with his
Nonce value to the blockchain,
it needs to be easy for the
other nodes in the network
to understand that this,
yes, this is a valid block.
And because it's valid,
it is the next block of the blockchain.
So this is how proof of work works, right?
All the miners try to
solve the hash puzzle
of finding the Nonce that together
with the other transaction
data gives them a valid block.
And the very first miner who comes up
with such a valid block
is then the one who can
kind of post his block
to the network and then
is selected by the others
as the next valid block.
Now, of course, the question
that is in the air is,
why would people even do that?
Why would people compete in such a way
and invest all that computing power,
which is quite a significant
amount of computing power,
in order to solve a block
and be chosen as the one
who composed this block to the network.
And this is due to the
introduction of incentives.
So pretty much every
blockchain system has some kind
of an incentive system
in order for miners,
which are basically the
nodes to engage in the system
and basically run the system.
And now very specifically,
especially for the bitcoin network,
the rewards are twofold.
The first kind of reward is something that
is called a block reward.
So the miner that is
chosen as being the one
who can post this block
to network gets a reward.
And this is quite a significant reward.
We'll later go into the details
for bitcoin in a moment.
So this is the block reward.
The second type of reward is something
like a transaction fee.
So if you are a user and
you post your transaction
to the memory pool, to the mempool,
which is the pool from which the miners
then pick up the transactions
and combine them into one block,
you need to pay in
transaction fee for the miner
to pick your transaction.
And this works more or less
like an open market place.
The miner can decide by himself
which transactions he want
to pick up and combine them in one block
and of course, the rational miner
will pick up those transactions first,
that gives him the
highest transaction fees.
So as a user, you can set
your own transaction fees.
And of course, the higher,
the faster your transaction
will be processed by the network.
And we will see in a later
lecture of this whole course,
how transactions fees evolved over time.
Now, let's dive into some specifics
of the bitcoin blockchain
because, of course,
bitcoin is the most prominent
user of proof of work.
So bitcoin does run proof of
work as in consensus mechanism,
and it is set up in a way
that the so called block
time amounts to 10 minutes.
The block time is the time
that the network takes
between adding a new block.
So every 10 minutes on average,
a new block is added to the network.
The block reward we talked
about earlier is 12.5 bitcoins.
So the miner who is chosen
as the one who kind of solves
the hash puzzle and then picks
the next block to be added
to the blockchain receives 12.5 bitcoin.
And this is, of course, a
very significant reward.
At the time of me recording this video,
one bitcoin fluctuates at around $10,000,
so 12.5 bitcoin will roughly be $120,000,
which is a very significant amount.
Another important piece of
information that you need
to be aware of is that for bitcoin,
the block reward halves
every 210,000 blocks.
And as one block takes about 10 minutes,
this is approximately four years.
So in the very beginning,
the block reward for
and finding the next
block was 50 bitcoins.
And since then, it is halving
approximately every four year.
This is just one specificity
of the bitcoin network.
And then another thing to
keep in mind on bitcoin
is that bitcoin
recalibrates the difficulty
of the hash puzzle it is
presenting to the miners.
So of course, the more
computing power is introduced
by miners to the network,
the quicker it would be in
order to solve the hash puzzle,
because more computers now can
in parallel with brute force,
try out different Nonce
values in order to come up
with a valid one.
And the more computing power you have,
the faster you will be
able to solve the puzzle.
And for this, this is
necessary to recalibrate
the difficulty of the hash puzzle
if you want to have the stable
block time of 10 minutes
for every block.
And in the bitcoin
network, every 2016 blocks,
which is approximately
14 days, so two weeks,
the bitcoin network recalibrates
the block difficulty
in order to make sure that the
block time always fluctuates
around 10 minutes.
This lecture focuses on an
alternative to proof of work.
It is proof of stake,
another consensus
mechanism that is endorsed
by some blockchains to solve the problem
that we just discussed earlier.
And let's just remind
us what the problem is.
The problem is that there
needs to be a next block,
or a race, there needs to be
a next block that is selected
to the blockchain network.
And there needs to be consensus
among all the participating nodes,
what the next block is going to be.
So how do we achieve consensus about
what the next block is going to be?
How do we collectively
decide on the next block?
And why we discussed in
detail how that works
with proof of work, which
is probably the most common
and the most popular consensus
mechanism at the moment.
Another consensus mechanism
that is gaining more
and more traction is proof of stake.
And probably the most popular
proponent of it is Ethereum.
So while Ethereum is
at the moment still ran
on proof of work,
it is very close to
implementing proof of stake
in the so called Casper update
in the very short feature.
So it is a highly relevant
consensus mechanism.
So, how does it work?
And the idea is that we are going away
from miners solving something
like hash puzzles needing
to invest huge amount of computing powers
in order to find some kind
of hash function output
that solves certain requirements.
It goes away from that,
and focuses more on users
investing certain amounts
of their coins,
so investing some kind of stake
that they have in the network,
in order to be able to then
be the one who has chosen
to propose the next block.
So in a bit more stylized way,
so let's imagine these guys are miners
and they want to become part
of the consensus mechanism.
So in order to do that,
they need to lock up a part of their funds
that they have in their network
in some kind of a virtual treasure locker.
So this means is that they're
locking these funds away
and won't be able to use them
for certain amount of time.
And what exactly that amount
of time is, of course,
largely differs by implementation
of the individual blockchains.
So now people have committed
to the consensus mechanism.
And now some kind of lottery
mechanism comes into play.
And the lottery mechanism
chooses now one of the miners
to be the one who can
propose the next block.
And it does so to a
certain extent randomly,
but it takes into account the size
of the individual coin holdings
that the miners have locked
up in order to participate
in this consensus mechanism
or in this lottery.
Another way to think about
it is that as a miner,
you can kind of contribute
or you can buy tickets
to the lottery, right?
And the more tickets you buy, of course,
the higher the chances are for you to win.
The more money you pay,
the more tickets you get.
But of course, even if you
have lots and lots of tickets,
while as others maybe have
only very few tickets,
there is no guarantee that in the end,
you are the one who actually wins.
Though the more tickets you
have, the higher your funds,
the higher your stake.
This is why it's called proof of stake.
The higher your stake,
the higher your chances
to be the one that is
then in the end selected
to propose the new block.
And I just want to mention the caveat
that this is a kind of simplified view
of how proof of stake works.
Most implementations can
have a much more complex,
the mechanics involved
and it's also very noteworthy
that there are lots
and lots of variations,
lots and lots of different implementations
that are either discussed
or already implemented
with some coins.
So, if you talk about proof of stake,
many people mean very
different things about that.
But I think that this is kind
of the common denominator,
the basic intuition that
you will need to understand
in order to understand
what this is all about.
That being said, why would
somebody need proof of stake?
So what are the advantages?
And one of the key advantages is that
it is much more energy efficient.
So many people criticize
blockchains like bitcoin
for the huge energy consumption.
At the moment, the whole bitcoin network
is allegedly consuming more energy
than some small countries.
So it is an extreme amount
of energy that is consumed
and the reason why it
consumes so much energy
are these miner farms,
which just have like the
huge amount of computers,
huge computer wrecks,
which just provide computing power
which provide hash power in
order to solve the hash puzzles
because the more
computing power you invest
into the network,
the higher your chances
of solving the next block,
and the higher your chances
of thereby getting the block reward,
which is quite significant
as we have seen.
So proof of stake doesn't
require computing power,
or not at least not even close
the amount of computing power
that is introduced by proof of work,
which is why proof of
stake can be a solution
to the sustainability problem
of blockchains like bitcoin.
Another advantage is that,
the block reward you need
to give out to the miners
isn't that high.
So the reason why in the bitcoin network
or other networks using proof of work,
the block rewards are
so high, so significant,
is because the miners
need to be compensated
for the huge amount of computing power
and electricity they
invest into the network.
As the costs of participating
in terms of just energy
and utility costs aren't
as high in proof of stake,
the block rewards don't
need to be as high.
And finally, the centralization risk
is supposed to not be as
high as proof of work.
If you control huge mining
farms in proof of work,
you can control the network.
And then this does pose
a risk of centralization
of the network, which of course,
goes against the decentralized
aspect of blockchain.
Of course, the counter
argument to proof of stake
is that with proof of stake,
the guy who owns the most coins, right,
the richest guy in the
system can be now the one
who gets the control over the network.
So it centralizes towards
rich people towards the wealth
to the our possibilities
to design proof of stake
in a way that this is not taking place.
So an easy way to think about
it would be to kind of cap
the maximum amount of
contributions that you get
by introducing high coin
values to the network.
The simple solution of just
capping it has disadvantages
and will be too complicated
to go into this at the moment,
but just understand that
there are kind of ways
in order to mitigate the problem.
And on the disadvantages side,
there is another very well known problem,
which is called nothing at stake problem.
And it describes the
problem that rational miners
and such proof of stake
regime might be incentivized
to produce fraudulent
invalid blocks all the time,
which then might congest the network
and might make it impossible for the nodes
to reach consensus.
If you would like to know more about this,
just google nothing at stake problem
and you will find extensive
documentation on that.
Could go into a bit more, too much detail
if we cover that here,
but if you Google it,
you will find lots of also
easy to understand explanations
about what the nothing at
stake problem is all about.
So thank you for watching.
I hope this video helped
you more about understanding
what consensus mechanism
really is all about.
If you took some value out of this video,
please press the like button.
And if you would like to
receive regular updates
of what's going on with this channel,
both on the frontier of career success,
but also learning new
technology such as blockchain,
press the...